Speaker 1: I'm told that Aubrey from
Wisconsin's microphone is fixed.
Let's see if that is true. Aubrey from
Wisconsin, welcome to the program. Let's
see if we can make it happen this time.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me this time?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can. AUBREY Welcome.
Speaker 4: Back. Hi, David. Thank you.
I'm so sorry. My phone's like schizo. Okay?
Speaker 1: Please don't swear, because as I've
told you during all of your previous phone calls,
we have to bleep when you swear for our radio
affiliates. Thank you.
Speaker 4:
I apologize. I apologize. Yeah. My phone is
schizophrenic. Really? About this. Okay. No,
I'm sorry. Don't be mad. I can hear
it. You're mad at me right now?
Speaker 1: No. I'm curious what you're bringing
to me today. Because you do. You do broach
interesting topics.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 4: Okay. I was going to mention
to you about, like, filters and stuff,
but I don't want to talk about the type I want to
talk about. I want to have. What is your take on
America and Israel? Right. Because right now.
Speaker 1: America and what ethereal.
Speaker 4: Is real Israel.
Speaker 1: Israel. The country of Israel.
Yeah. Hello?
Speaker 4: No, because this happened, like, a
week ago. I want to ask you this. Yeah. Yeah. Me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Okay. Okay. Yeah, Because this
happened, like, a week ago, and I was, like,
muted on your server, actually, because we started
someone going get into it. She was very rich,
man. Anyways, so this, like, happened. We go
there like, they, like, bombed a military weapons,
whatever and Iran and like, if this was like any
other country, this would started World War three.
But you know, because it's sweet. Maybe Israel
America didn't care because, you know, we put
them up with money. And I'm a proud Palestinian
Lebanese woman, as you can see, like, you know,
and I'm like, you know, I'm an Arab girl. So that
like, you know, I just like once you see your
head, click, Do you think that, like, America will
ever stop pumping Israel with money? Or do you
think that, like, you know, they're just going to
take over the entirety of Palestine and, you know,
do everything they want whatever the heck they
want? That's what I said. I didn't say anything.
Speaker 1: AUBREY you know, you've
broached such a massive issue,
which is the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
Speaker 4: I couldn't comment. So
I have the right to say it.
Speaker 1: Oh, I didn't. I'm
not questioning your right. I'm just saying I
couldn't possibly thoroughly respond to what
you're saying in this format. But what I do want
to tell you is that I have dozens of videos with
what I believe is the only real credible path to
peace in the Middle East on my YouTube channel.
And I outline it in detail, including what I
believe the borders would be, what I believe
leadership on both sides would have to look
like, etc.. And so I would recommend checking
out some of some of those segments, I think.
Speaker 4: But do you think it's crazy that
they're able to do that? Probably. Okay.
Speaker 1: Aubrey. Aubrey, Aubrey, you're
swearing completely uncontrollably. Okay. Let's
see if we can simmer the situation a little bit.
I believe that a two state solution is
the only likely path to peace. I don't
know that I believe current leadership
on either side is credibly going to get
us there. And I encourage you to check out my
material on on the YouTube channel about it.
Speaker 4: Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you. And, Aubrey,
remind us you're not from Long Island, right?
Speaker 4: No, I'm from Wisconsin. Wisconsin.
Speaker 1: Okay, very good. All right. Aubrey,
great to hear from you. I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Thank you. Have a great day.
Speaker 1: You, too. There goes Aubrey
from Wisconsin. Let's take just a very quick
break to recover from that. And once we've
reconstituted our energy, we're going to
come right back and take more calls. So
if you are waiting on the discord, please
don't hang up. We'll be right back to it.